welcome everybody to the h3 podcast live
thank you to our sponsors today stitch
fix min Squarespace and Bolin branch
today we have Bobbie Lee the hilarious
and infamous pants [ __ ] Bobbie Lee
the comedian and community and comedian
and shooter he was on MADtv
he has a podcast that he slams and he's
just saw all around funny cool dude but
today before we get into that he's gonna
be joining us later I was feeling like
it's time to try a new format on the
podcast here because we've had like a
ton of interviews in a row and while I
and I love interviewing and spending
time with guests I feel like kind of the
heart and soul of the podcast should be
me complaining and hila listening and I
thought there hasn't been enough of me
complaining Andy listening losing it
and so I'm losing it and so what we were
thinking is that the first 30 minutes to
45 minutes should be me Neela talking
about what's going on talking about
what's bothering me what's not going on
and what's going in all right or out at
the same time you know there's lots of
twists and turns there's no coffee
there's no water on the table now I'm a
straight up diva okay I'm a pate I'm a
diva but I'm also a patient in forgiving
man okay and I can only I can only
tolerate so many what did I do to
reserve to deserve this disrespect
there's no glass of water on the table
we've got I would like a glass of water
though we need 30 minutes for no respect
got like a full staff of people back
here we get a glass of water
what are you looking at shredder anyway
what was I saying
I don't hear water pouring it's on its
way so we thought it would be we should
we should have our own thing you know
it's a we should take the time to talk
and see what's going on because there's
all kinds of stuff I want to talk about
so let's just get let's just get right
thank you Dan oh that's not Dan that's
in you guys beards are a melding into
one identity so first of all so yeah
Bobbie Lee will be here in about 30
minutes looking forward to that our okay
so we had a live show last month at the
improv with post Malone and it was it
was a ton of fun it was so much fun it
was exhilarating so incredible yeah like
so there was 200 seats there and the
thing about the improv is like there's
no real green room or backstage so you
have to walk through the crowd to get
there and when we walked through
everyone was just like so freaking
supportive and high-energy
it was incredible you walk out it's like
embarrassing in a way right you know
what I mean yeah cuz it's like
everyone's like so how you want to you
and it's like me so our first show was a
total blast our next live show is this
month on the 26th at the Ace theater
downtown LA the tickets are on sale you
can spam it
can you guys spam it and we'll also put
it in the description of YouTube but
this one's a 1,700 seater at the ACE
theater I am terrified I'm terrified
1,700 seats and I thought I could barely
talk more than like normally I can
barely talk right more than normal I
think you're being hard on yourself no
but I did find it interesting that so
Austin was like he was telling us that
he was super nervous and he's played
shows way bigger than that but I guess
it's it's different cuz he just goes
many things and he does something that's
really comfortable and used to doing but
going up in front of an audience like
talking and [ __ ] as a whole it's a whole
different I guess skills yeah so he said
he was super nervous up there which I
thought was cute
we were all so nervous raw I was
purified before I have to even talk
about this no I don't think we did see
that's the problem with this show what's
the point of the podcast if I can't even
talk about like that whole experience so
I was so I was just [ __ ] myself
backstage as we were waiting and then
Austin came like two minutes before we
were it was late and we're waiting in
the stairwell and of course he's always
on time it's the coolest guy he comes
cruising up the stairs and we barely
have enough time to snap a photo but I'm
just like I don't know how to describe
that feeling it's just yeah it's it's
excitement and nervousness and all kinds
of nuts there's like no words exactly
yeah I don't know so I'm wondering but
the thing about The Improv is that it's
so intimate there that you can like see
everybody's face
like the first row we're pretty much
like they're sitting right but I think
at the ACE you're not going to
necessarily see everybody in there so in
a weird way I expect it to be less
stressful in that you don't feel like
you're entertaining like people are like
staring at you waiting for to be
entertained in a way you know yeah
you're like when is the joke coming
exactly you're just staring almost until
like a black void because the lights are
so bright you can't really see anything
so that's really exciting I'm super
pumped and what the plan is that we want
to do it every month
and I think what we want to do is that
at the 8th every month like a residency
so we'll do it at the our last show of
every month at the ACE and we'll put our
tickets on sale for the whole year
probably next month after we see how
this one goes if I don't tank if I don't
bomb completely what's the worst-case
scenario like what would be the worst
bomb what if I just walked out and broke
my leg that's what they say brick you're
like what
I just tripped and broke my leg that
won't be that bad code it's not your
fault it's almost like thank you
goodnight no refund that actually
happened I saw a conference at Blizzcon
they had this is the funny [ __ ] in can
you try to find that or someone back
there at Blizzcon they have a costume
competition and everyone comes out in
their costumes and someone literally
came out and broke their leg it had to
be carried off the stage and I know it
sounds tragic but it was hilarious
can you find it in meanwhile I wanted to
talk about our last video Ethan's closet
because coroner Ethan says yeah that's
how much I care about it it had everyone
so polarized it was it was a shitty
video I mean I knew that it was just a
goof right it's funny we actually had
people unsubscribing like a lot from
that video it doesn't really bother me I
just find it funny that like years of
posting content and then all of a sudden
they're like nope maybe they had it
maybe that was it you know what Ethan
I've had enough with your videos because
the was this is it goodbye forever
you couldn't find forever here's the
video by the way this is important this
is more important than whatever I'm
talking about oh yeah this is definitely
it good it to get you guys are not this
is this is this is what's gonna happen
to me I can't wait he like immediately
just Oh
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
get it Daniel you shouldn't laugh but I
yeah he pretty much he sprained his
ankle or really he's [ __ ] up
he won't even attempt to stand up he's
just like you know what I'm done someone
carry my heads up and that's what
happens it's a huge security guy scary
though bro you you have one good leg
just stand up and hop off God Christ
she's also super nervous it's the most
but you yeah okay but I mean you've got
adrenaline just cop hobble off crawl off
stage if you have to just get on just
crawl out you're in the trenches man
those shells fall out
[Laughter]
look at this all these guys come on
carriers as out look at this they
grabbed him by the this is too good
have you ever seen this batter sight in
your life he's grabbing his broken ankle
[Applause]
[Laughter]
there's this moment here of like a face
that you'll never forget that moment
here it is
Oh makeup doesn't help so that's the
worst case scenario very much
I can relate last night I fell oh yeah
in our stairs yeah we moved into a new
house Hertz it's got pretty steep stairs
it was when I was just standing there
and he was coming down the stairs
language shredder it's dangerous and
Healy just ate [ __ ] like she just
skipped the last stair here and it
looked weird cuz it looked almost like
she meant to do it but nothing hit hard
she tumbled she timbered right there
remember anyway so I can't really who
can relate okay you can so anyway the
last video was a real ship post and a
lot of people were upset some people
liked it some people didn't which is
fine I I tried to tell you guys I was
gonna post shitty videos did I not say
that and everyone remember when we were
like oh I've been depressed oh I've been
depressed it took a little while from
that moment yeah I should have followed
it up with this but you know I just felt
like posting a video I didn't care about
what it was it wasn't you know but
anyway this mean was really funny on the
sub right I love this this family man
the new HTC reach video was [ __ ] it's
the return of classic h3 it's forced and
full of half-baked jokes and builds up
to absolutely nothing
he is alerting people on the Facebook
privacy scam was maintaining a good
balance between information and shed
posting all he did was say Facebook and
AIDS 50 times can it be both I feel like
it can be both I feel like the truth is
somewhere in the middle I don't know
what is this from its it's from pawn or
these are the it's called a West Coast
Choppers are the West Coast boys I love
that just he's throwing it like a really
capture yeah the feeling of those coins
right like exactly exactly anyway guys
we just posted a new video that I'm I'm
happy with it I like it
we're trying to get back into the swing
of it
you know that's two videos the longer
you don't post it gets harder to get
back to it right so we're just trying to
break that that's what it was and
there's like a wall seal yeah and that's
what that video Ethan's corner was cuz
you just okay you make a video it's not
as good as you want maybe it's you don't
think it's good at all but at a certain
point you just got to post it and move
on you just because then what you don't
post it and then you get even more
depressed and then you try to make
another video game order I am at the
point where I just want to post it and
move on because I feel like I need to be
creative I need to be just moving
forward all the time because lately I've
been so depressed and so stuck and so
just like stuck in the same thoughts in
the same head in the same space and I
just I feel like I need to slam through
that yeah blast through all that and
like not working slash posting videos
they go together not doing that gets
more depressing you'd you lose like your
purpose what are we doing here alright
what and we've been putting too much
well stuff that we've been putting too
much emphasis on the podcast
it's just that it's become the only
thing yeah and and and maybe I was
almost just overcome compensating for
the fact we're making I don't know
but we need to find a balance because I
was thinking back like to a year-plus
ago when we were posting like two or
three videos a week and for me that was
it really it was really cool it was a
good time for me because I was always
creating something new I was being
creative and I was just expressing
myself more authentically than always
trying to I don't know whatever
I've been dude I've been I've got I I'm
gonna be real I have a bottle of
antidepressants and next to my bed and I
take it out and I stare at it and I
think last night I was like having a
breakdown this [ __ ] like there's this
Amazon [ __ ] like we had these guys
install tea
and there's such buffoons these guys are
such meatheads they install it so close
to the [ __ ] wall you can't plug
anything in now and now it's installed
on a mount so I've got this Amazon stick
so I want to watch YouTube or whatever
and I'm trying to plug it in and I can
feel the socket every I have to rip the
TV off the wall and jam my hand up back
there and I was like almost bleeding my
hand and I I could feel the socket and
it was just about to go and but it
wouldn't go in
okay and I was at this for like an hour
I was like OCD obsessed I was losing my
mind
I felt like I was aware of how insane I
was acting but I couldn't stop it was so
[ __ ] close to get in the hole and all
the time I know that I'm such a lunatic
but I can't stop trying to get and I was
like dude this I'm so [ __ ] twisted
evil is coming in because I'm screaming
like a lunatic and she's like she's like
what's wrong with you I'm like I don't
know she's like that's not normal is
like I know dude but I gotta get the
damn stick in the hole you know it's
like this little thing which I became
obsessed with it was just manic so I
just stopped eventually and but I've
been like she's been I just felt like
I'm being crazy lately I got this bottle
of antidepressants next to my bed I'm
like like it's I think it's time but
then I realized I never actually put in
the work and taking antidepressants is
like it's either the easy way out or you
already tried everything and so you
should take it because there's no reason
to suffer but I'm like this is the easy
escape because I there's a direct
correlation between me being fat and
lazy and not taking care of myself and
me being depressed and like I'm I'm on
an upward trajectory right now and I'm
like I can't take these if I'm not
exercising if I'm not eating right I'm
not treating myself well it's all
connected yeah there's a direct
correlation between all that [ __ ] so I
don't know I've been I've been that was
a couple days ago I've been exercising
I've been trying to eat better cuz I'm
not you know
you got to put in the work yourself to
fix yourself before you take well that
would be just a shortcut some people
need antidepressants but I don't know if
I do because I haven't actually tried to
help myself yet enough to warrant it so
I'm just like I got to do something
so I'm trying I'm trying this is all
part of the same thing I'm trying to
trying to exercise I'm trying to treat
myself better trying to just post videos
be more creative in that way man though
dude I'm gonna get that [ __ ] stick in
that hole I swear to God that stick is
going in that hole can we take off the
TV I tried dude I was like I was pulling
the string I was like it's a big TV too
and I was always yeah we can take it off
there's a easy way to do it
but it just seemed it was like it was so
sick it felt like a biblical like
metaphor because it was within reach and
it was totally doable you just slide
your hand up and it's just a little
awkward and it's like you know what I
mean it's like get in the hole I was
literally yelling and I'm just like it's
doable that was the hardest part but I
just couldn't get it in I know there's
meaning somewhere in there I don't know
where it is I know it's a yeah yeah well
join the club
what else some will lunatic went to
YouTube and try to kill everybody there
you know when that news broke that there
was a shooting at YouTube here's this
[ __ ] want to show you guys this but
let me talk about this a little bit when
I heard there was a shooting active
shooter there the first thought I had
was like please God don't let this be
some disgruntled loser youtuber I was
like please the world is not that we
haven't gone that low have we
and then at first they said it was a
girlfriend who shot her boyfriend or
whatever and I was like great I was like
okay thank God well weird that it
happened at YouTube yeah but then it was
no is just even started that rumor I
have no idea is that strange
yeah well and besides that I have I know
people who work there but I have one
really close friend some of them
actually care about who works there and
I was like I was so worried because
there was no anything yeah and you
didn't know how bad it was and I texted
him and he didn't he didn't answer me
right away so I was like I was concerned
and not only that but you care on the
level that you know it's a traumatic
event for them hmm and you know that
things aren't gonna be the same now at
YouTube and Twitter and Facebook and all
these people do like you know it's
almost like it's not the same anymore
because now the seals been broken and
all of a sudden someone who's angry at
how you treated I was gonna come try to
murder you but anyway this lunatic
she was just thought that YouTube was
suppressing her views but honestly her
videos just suck and they're weird which
is the case in most of the time I have
to say if your fellow youtuber listening
this and you think that there's a giant
conspiracy to to reduce your views that
could be right to an extent but for the
most part if you're not getting abused
it's probably because your videos suck
and your fans are tired of your [ __ ]
that's way more likely that's probably
75% of it at least and in her case it's
like yeah there's no conspiracy your
shits weird
I heard sometimes that happens it
doesn't even matter right that's not
even sure even if they did I guess I'm
just addressing her point that it's like
people are entitled to be like well
anyway it doesn't matter you're right
but my friend who works there was saying
like that
that uh she was she had a handgun and
luckily shouldn't have something more
dangerous or more deadly with more
rounds but he said there was like a busy
lunch area where everyone was eating and
she came up and just started shooting
people randomly but she was firing into
a glass door lunch so he was saying if
she actually was was trying to trying to
hit more people there could have been a
lot it could have been a lot worse
I don't know what's going on the weird
thing too is the police saw her found
her in her car up near YouTube studios
because her dad called the police and
was like my daughter or maybe her
brother family member my daughter or
family member is super angry at YouTube
and she's dangerous
really yeah he said they said I think
she's gonna do something and so the
police found her sleeping in her car and
they let her go
what because well the police said she
was fine she wasn't she didn't seem
dangerous but I don't know it's like
it's the same [ __ ] that happened with
this recent school shooting it's like
every every sign was like this kid is
dangerous he's deranged let's keep an
eye on him you know I'm glad that that
it wasn't worse don't say that
another thing that really was insane
about this whole thing was all the
comments everywhere
yeah everyone she said what happened
yeah like Oh YouTube deserved it that
was obvious I knew it was coming and I
was just like but I saw so many and then
upwards do ya cuz everybody's got to be
edgy little everyone's so edgy and no
one can take anything seriously it's
like the ultimate mean you know mm-hmm
shooting at YouTube me oh my god so much
mean potential I'm gonna make a joke
that I'm not supposed to do whatever
these edgy kids will grow up someday um
other stuff there's a lot of other stuff
but Bobby just arrived so I actually
have a lot of more stuff to talk about
but we can talk about it next time yeah
and then just get in with Bobby
so let's do that
let's do that for pizzas sake shall we
it's two for two when do we start how
long we've been going to 15 so well I
went by fast okay great
there's a couple of the lawsuit our
lawsuit and talk about this don't we'll
bring Bob in our lawsuit with Matt Haas
got published so it's now officially
case law it was like a big deal its
publishing a bunch of law journals and
there was like 38 different legal
precedents with death yeah with
defamation and copy wrong so it's like
law students are gonna be studying that
[ __ ] now I thought I learned so much
about law yeah what a what a crazy thing
man and yeah there was something funny
about it like the lawyer who actually
did all the work I was asking him he's
not getting any credit because he was
credited as an associate he's like weird
how the whole thing works
oh there's like a head lawyer but yeah
yeah so so there's a head lawyer that we
actually didn't like at all and we're
like please don't please don't involve
him I remember what happened but
something weird happened and then the
associate guy who's like a little tiny
foot mark did everything he was working
full-time on this [ __ ] writing all
these amazing documents he is incredible
lawyer and he's not getting like any
credit so there you go life's a [ __ ]
yeah and this one guy who did literally
nothing isn't like getting all the
credit the one guy who were like I don't
even want to talk to this guy cuz I
don't trust him
oh I know you know what this guy did the
guy who's in charge used to do all this
[ __ ] like we were spending so much
money and we're not Microsoft right he
knows we're just a couple of kids he'll
do this [ __ ] like when I'm being deposed
okay so the lawyer who did all the work
is they're giving me counsel in the
deposition this other guy without asking
my permission or consulting is listening
on the phone the whole time and never
says anything okay
and heat so so that's eight hours and he
charges $650 an hour and he charges us
for all eight hours so that ends up
being like 1020 thousand dollars and I'm
like bro like what the hell just don't
listen ROM was fine and he does all
these little [ __ ] like rack up the
bill and doesn't do anything so anyway
congratulations to our attorneys god
bless
ela said is it okay to talk about this I
don't know it's not details of the case
so I think probably okay it's not like
um it's not like sealed you sure you
want to mess with lawyers all right now
you scare the [ __ ] okay
and then you gotta like type it is we
have a little private discord he feels
like you sure you want to talk about
this and now you make me anxious and now
you're calling me out it well I can't
not acknowledge that because now I'm
anxious on camera cuz I'm just gonna
look at it and be like like this it's
too late or you talked about it it's
gonna be like this I'm just gonna do one
of these and it's like well no it's fine
all right so that's it so let's bring
Bobby Lee in we're gonna take a quick
commercial break we will be right right
right right right right back with Bobby
Lee it's gonna be a ton of fun it's
gonna be a total blast you are not gonna
want to miss this it's gonna be so
insane so guys we will see you in a
brief moment Dan take it away
thank you to stitch fix for sponsoring
this episode you can tell when our guys
got style
when they don't when they're looking
this good well looking this good a
t-shirt and a hat and unshowered isn't
easy shower I shower last night okay so
I'm not completely unsure but you know
what I mean
you can tell when a guy's showered that
should be the start of their coffee you
can tell when a guy's showered order a
shower guys it's tough to find clothing
out there it's hard enough to go to the
mall I don't even know where to buy
clothing let alone what to buy
that's why stitch fix is so awesome you
sign up they give you a personal stylist
a K your mom or girlfriend in virtual
reality who cares about you unlike your
real mom maybe that's just me I don't
know my mom loves me but this person is
gonna it's their job to make you look
great yeah tell them your sizes how much
you want to spend what your interview
your preferences and then this like this
genius designer is gonna send you an
outfit they're just gonna it's gonna
transform you you know you're gonna be a
new guy just like Dan out here our
producer he's got a sweater he hasn't
taken it off it's disgusting but
apparently he's getting a lot of female
attention since you put that sweater on
stitch fix is the new way to shop for
clothing and it's unbelievably simple so
the items get delivered right to your
home you try them on and you only pay
for what you keep it's risk free for
crime it's crime and he's sake what is
crime how many I've heard that before
but I know that mean crime you say just
send everything you don't want back
shipping is free both ways for criminy
sakes does it get any better try him out
today guys you have got nothing nothing
to lose so get started now at stitch fix
calm slash h3 you'll also get 25% off
when you keep all five items in your box
that's stitch fix calm slash a story to
get started a stitch fix calm slash h3
go there get some bomb-ass clothes this
designers gonna hook you up thank you to
stitch fix god bless you appreciate you
you the best great yeah
next up we've got Squarespace I love
Squarespace can I tell you why I love
Squarespace yes they're gonna change
your life they're gonna fulfill every
dream and fantasy you've ever had that's
a bit of oversell they just build they
help you build a website but really cool
but here yeah really sleek website right
they've got templates they've got how do
you call it templates I guess I've got
like a bunch of templates
they make building a beautiful slick
website for if you're selling something
if you have a vlog if you just want to
make our e-portfolio our portfolio or
maybe you just want to share pictures of
your use your imagination you sicko
maybe you just want to [ __ ] you know
whatever it is they've got the template
and the tools so even if you're not a
NASA scientist you can go and make the
website of your dreams that's how
powerful and how simple and beautiful it
is I cannot endorse them enough they
give you the templates they create the
beautiful websites all in one platform
they allow you manage your products
orders in inventory they track sales
give you customer insights and grow your
customer base all within their
management and analytical tools they
make it easy to learn by providing
webinars workshops and 24/7 customer
support okay
it's incredible and they make it simple
to set up and transfer your domain but
you've got no excuse you guys try
squarespace for free for 14 days and
receive 10% off your purchase of a
website or domain it's risk free get in
there
give it a shot 14 days free you're gonna
love it right head on over
squarespace.com slash h3 god bless you
appreciate you and finally we have got
Bowen branch ok Boland branch they make
bed sheets right Wow who cares no you
didn't realize how comfortable bed
sheets can be until you've rolled around
in the lavender and fluffy cloud feels
that is a bowline branch bed sheet until
you roll in the
until you roll in the bowl I mean have
you ever rolled in the bowl my doggies
here's the deal you think that getting a
great night's sleep is up to like Oh an
expensive mattress or an expensive
pillow the sheet plays just as an
important role and that's what people
don't realize because it's it's got a
breathe
it's got to be soft not too soft though
if it's all silk it's like oh wow it's
just slips right off you like Teflon I
don't need that but it's the perfect
medium okay everything they make from
bedding the blankets is made from pure
100% organic cotton which means they
start off soft and they get even softer
over time you buy directly from them so
you're essentially paying wholesale
prices luxury sheets can cost up to a
thousand dollars and frankly you'd have
to be psychotic to pay that I don't know
who pays a thousand dollars I'm just
gonna say that flat out but if you go to
Bowen branch there are only a couple
hundred bucks so that's like a massive
discount everyone who tries Bowen branch
loves them that's just that's just a
fact of life that's why they have
thousands of five-star reviews Forbes of
Wall Street Journal and Fast Company are
all talking about Bowen branch I just
walked into the day I was like oh my god
have you heard of Bowland branch I was
like [ __ ] dude who are you why are you
talking to me three u.s. presidents
sleep on Boland branch apparently we
haven't fact checked that taking their
word for it shipping is free and you can
try them for 30 nights that's an insane
offer try it for 30 nights it's that
simple if you don't like it if it's not
worth it send it back that's awesome
if you don't lend them send them back
for free for a refund I doubt you're
gonna want to send them back because
there's no risk and there's no reason
not to give it a try so get started
right now my listeners get $50 off your
first set of sheets at bowl and branch
comm use the promo code h3 go to bowl
and branch comm today for $50 off your
first set of sheets
that's bol el and branch com promo code
h3 bowl and branch com promo code Ashley
thank you so much to our sponsors and
now let's watch and talk with your boy
Bobby Lee hey welcome back everybody
here with the funny great wonderful
Bobby Lee oh my god thank you so much
for saying that oh thank you for being
here it's really cool to have you here I
was kind of looking forward to it
because people on the Internet's yeah is
that how you say it you could say yeah
and they were like you weren't are you
gonna do it and then I for like weeks
and now I'm here I can't believe it
that's really I can swear [ __ ] yeah oh
yeah yeah it's so good why you can't
swear on your podcast no I can but it's
like some places I go and they're like
you can't swear or talk about like your
penis or and things like that and I'm
talking about your penis Oh talk about
your feet I encourage you to talk about
your feet my feet I want to get my left
foot my left foot is a disaster zone
what happened because um well I don't
wash it and then also what do you shower
or bathe and people but pick your feet
out no no what happened was years ago I
started going to the Korean spa and then
my feet started getting Ichi's and then
all of a sudden I went to the hospital
and they said um that I have like stage
9 gangrene on my left foot what like put
foot fungi are you serious nah don't
it's not like operable you cut it off no
no it's not at that level no it's not
like Vietnam War like you know level and
so so what I saw your feet you're
wearing sandals in it they look like the
bottom of our disaster can I see no no
no maybe afterwards you won't show I've
never shown anybody I mean you're
wearing open sandals the whole anyone
walking behind you can see it no I know
but they need to breathe that's why like
I go to New York like during like
snowstorm yeah I don't wear sandals
people like what [ __ ] you don't
happens if you wear shoes and socks it
gets worse on in the itchiness gets
worse and then they give me an ointment
and I refuse to put it on why because
well I put on my right foot but my left
foot I like a ditch a why I like
scratching it so you are intentionally a
promoting gangrene on your face that
gangrene it's like the foot fungi so
you're promoting [ __ ] fungi for the joy
of itching it yeah I just might end them
my girlfriend like 4:00 in the morning
this is what she hears
that's pretty twisted yeah yeah I gotta
admit yeah it's pretty twisted yeah why
if the relief though doesn't cause
belief it's like
good I I'm I'm more along the line of
Bobby in that like if I have a bite I'll
H it off yeah then I'm done I like it
when it bleeds a little bit I don't
necessarily go after the blood but you
don't you know I'm a blood guy for sure
all day every day you were you're a sick
man and I like it then it dries and then
that the scab happens and sometimes it
depends on how I feel I sometimes it'll
eat it I believe you have you ever used
to get your own scab
why do you eat it I feel I have to say
[Laughter]
about about the experience of eating
your own it's like home jerky oh my god
like Madden man made jerky that you're
making on your body
would you ever eat another person's no
no no I can only add my own booger as my
own scabs and stuff like you what what's
the matter do you eat would you you eat
your own boogers so do this I have tried
well not every day not every day but
I've got a couple times a year I've done
it here's the thing so what okay so let
me follow that cuz is it just like when
you have a nice fat juicy satisfying
burger that you pop it in like a tic-tac
no I mean you know what I do what other
humans do is that you know you pick your
nose and then you roll into a ball I do
that
there we go right I don't that's the
truth put in your mouth and let me just
say this right now I'm in my 40s so um
you know I'm an adult so I don't do it
every day
I don't do it even once a month but a
couple times a year right I'll roll a
nice ball I'll look at it there's if
there's different colors in it
like a little blood a little bit of like
a darker or like grayish thing and if
it's like juicy and hard at the same
time sometimes I pop it in if it just
looks because let me say this right now
my friend how is that disgusting it came
from inside me yeah but so yeah just put
it back inside some things that come
from your body aren't meant to go back
in like [ __ ] its excrement it's waste oh
that's true I don't do [ __ ] and piss
that's right that's a good point maybe
maybe we need to yeah but can I just say
this kind of make it it but there's also
a taste to it that's a little satisfying
right I'm a salt man so
I know that people eat boogers yeah I
just I'm not saying this to like hide my
shame yeah never eaten a booger you've
never eaten a booger I know everything
like kids do it but yeah have you ever
smelled your own calm well I haven't
like I am not that way yeah me too is
like it when you come in on that dry
when come dries it has a smell well I've
never dried come when do we feel like
you have like a little farm I do I come
from in your bathroom sometimes if
you're at home by yourself and you're
feeling pretty - pretty couple lonely
yeah it's and then all the sudden
there's like a whole pile of comrades
oh yeah bad there's a smell yeah what is
a smell like I'll tell you what it
smells I'm able to be exposed to
chlorine yeah does it not smell like
chlorine it does have a smoke Lauren
yeah we almost wanted we open wrong know
this yeah yeah we open although we're
not well what I want to go back no this
is a perfect opening of this is that I
see you're vaping and I know you're a
vapor yeah we have a vape that is
somewhat ceremonial here at our show
sure and we wanted to know if you would
try hitting our babe I would I'll do
whatever you want me to do bring it in
yeah yeah show me your feet you'll be
the person my girlfriend you'll be the
first one to see it on camera yeah I
don't want to show it to the camera
though you can look at it what what is
this oh my God look at this is no joke
I'm sober so it can't be marijuana
though yeah I don't want to I don't want
to relapse on your show it's not even
tobacco
it's just vapor this is so here's the
button here yeah you just push and suck
what kind of flavor is it it's a unicorn
don't I love Donuts
so here's I don't want to mmm so you
have to push the button when you okay so
if you want to rip it fat as possible
it's not a competition but people are
competing I don't have when you rip up
that
when you cough the smoke disappears I
don't want to do it again you absorbed
all that thank you man it's a
hundred-fifty battery mod but did you
get it for free or did you on paper we
we've paid a lot of money for that oh my
god we paid dearly
we had a sacrifice to intern he wasn't
that good did you - me - entender how
did you guys mean man you know what I
it's funny I I feel so bad a way for
people who are like on tinder it seems
rough
we met pre tinder all pre tender that's
great I met my girlfriend on tinder
really love exists on tinder yeah I know
a lot of relationships that start on
tinder I mean that's just how people
date these days yeah it's like how do
you meet people anyway I know if I was
single now I wouldn't know how to meet
yeah but you know what tinder is great
because you'd run into people yeah a lot
of it's like you know hit and runs you
know just tap it and then you go right
some people use tinder for that aspect I
used it for love and it worked I I
swiped right on kalila it was my third
day and matter three days in well I did
my third yeah my third date I had
already got out with two other people
she's my third one and then yeah and
then I've been with her since Wow that's
five years is the best endorsement of
tinder ever a cool yeah I mean you can
tap and run I did that for the first two
right yeah but you feel guilty about
that I like tapping a running well do
you not think that they wanted to tap
and run maybe no because I'm never a
one-night stand I'm like if if I get if
I girls want to have sexual sexualities
with me can I say it that way it's got
to be a little girl but sorry but it's
got to be long-term I've never been like
I had a friend named Callisto and we
would go to a bar and girls would look
at him and go yeah I'll [ __ ] that for
one night right but they would look at
me as like I only [ __ ] that that's a
relationship right right anyway I have
to I have to be in a relationship for me
to get any kind of sexualities
interesting yeah what do you mean what I
don't know just listen you know I relate
because a guy that looks like me we I
think we have similar yeah because
because like I'm not I'm not like King
dong I'm not a Jack I'm not handsome
thank you for the endorsement and I feel
the same way about you as well
we can just write abrogate we look like
somebody drew us but yeah yeah you're
like we're like not real human but like
Tim Burton what I'm gonna experiment
alright yeah yep what so I saw you a
question we met in Israel on birthright
what do you know what that is
what it's like it's it's a weird thing
where it's it's it's a bunch of rich
Zionist send young Jews to Israel for
free or free trip and the hope that like
they are and they're gonna learn about
is birthing in you a joy for the Jewish
motherland right I move there it worked
but I took her back so it failed no you
took her from there yeah I'm gonna move
together back that back together yeah I
lived there for five years it was a long
process of going back and forth oh wow I
live there five years we got married and
then we got a green card and said smell
you later
are you Jewish yes can you not tell tell
really yeah Eva doesn't really have a
Jewish thing cuz she's she's a she's she
look Jewish no she looks uh no you look
artistic though that's no you look like
somebody that was like an artist from
the 40s not that you know into the age
I'm not saying that you look old no I
think there's a photo of you like these
are Spanish art oil painters from the
40s Maya and your face was in there I'd
be like yeah I believe that's special
what do I look like you look like that
be real and IIIi need any harsh
criticisms well the way you're dressed
now I wouldn't be surprised to see you
toss in some you know beef and broccoli
yeah but tossing oh because you've got
like a chef thing and you've got a
beanie on yeah Wow good nice hair now
now that everything now is different
thank you you look like you could be
dropping some bomb-ass - it's for a
marketing company thank you so much so I
look yeah yeah thank you
that hair could get you by and you know
what kind of race I am
or at your Korean how'd you know I read
cheerfully Korean for sure yeah you know
what do you what about me
did you write em I know right well
that's not really but like what country
am i from you're from America yeah yeah
everything about you is America yeah but
I was I was coming you know what you do
now if I look at your arms
you are Jewish what does that mean what
did you recognize well it's just say uh
III gotta like I gotta say this and I uh
I gotta think about what I'm saying here
just say it just be blunt no I don't
wanna be bothered I want you don't want
to be blunt no because I have friends
yeah okay
that our writers like my friend David
King you know David King he's a great
writer
I love you were wrote for love okay you
guys have the same arms and hands right
okay and I I don't even meet I don't
even know what that means you just they
just look similar and so that's all I'm
gonna yeah that's all I'm gonna say but
I get the sense that you're trying to
get at something no you just have a
Jewish man's body okay that's my do you
know I call them and go get like skinny
arms because oh yeah ya know I've always
that I've always known that I'm both fat
and skinny at the same time that's all I
say that's fine and I'm not trying to
make fun of you but you you have like a
very like you have like and you have a
similar body I've seen you shirtless
bless you and you know or thank you
you've like got the whole thing like
real you know I did this to my own body
well I did yeah well you over are you
implying that I'm just somehow doomed to
these pudgy folds these doughy this
doughy prison so I used to be fit I
played water polo yeah in high school
yeah I was tanned I had curly hair and
girls wanted to suck my dick believe it
not that I ever losing you of laughing
unfuckable I wasn't [ __ ] for about a
year yeah my life were you ever [ __ ]
I don't think I ever was because the
thing is is that I grew up I'm older
than I am so in the what I'm older than
people think I am how old are you
well guess I would guess that you're
about 40 when you said all right
forty-seven that's why great really god
bless you really
god bless you I look great on you don't
have any grip or anything I guess before
you said 37 I honestly would have
guessed I would I just say something I
love Israel and I was gonna guess lower
but I knew I guess on the high side wow
look at that
look your face is deceiving but with the
whole situation I would say 38 it's a
rough life though but in a way in a way
I like because it's like I still have
life ahead of me alright oh my god it's
you yeah but like on average yeah yeah
yeah let's say it's what it is is the
the sprinkly white yeah it doesn't help
that don't help
he had it since I when we met it was 21
and he already had the white hair he did
yeah yes so that's you know my life but
also it's kind of [ __ ] if I wasn't a
pudgy dobar I just imagine a world where
I'm George Clooney that's it no just
imagine that world for a second yeah and
I know I'm a guest on your podcast right
but there's no [ __ ] way maybe George
Clooney there you're not in the same
category I think that I just luckily
you're not ugly but you're not George
Clooney I just did imagine a world I try
on fat show him fat you know that is
he's the guy from Crouching Tiger and
Dragon that's right there we go you're
like you're the guy who got this [ __ ]
the shirtkin in the forehead man no
you're not Shelly I'm fat thank you
you're Clooney I'm you know what I'm not
offended but yeah ii-i've never have
been deluded about like go back what you
said like you I'm not the kind of guy
the girls are just like oh I want to
[ __ ] that guy yeah I'm either and that's
what you mean you have to you have to
woo them you have to romance them you
have to be like hey you know there's
other things I can cook right but could
I just say this I can a great point
where you're making yeah okay because if
I was from the gate a guy that women
wanted to have sex with I wouldn't have
developed
that portion of my personality to drive
me into what to drive me into where I
went yeah I agree
do I understand and I agree
I used humor as a defense mechanism
exact because I was picked on and
whatnot
yeah and and because I didn't get girls
in high school and whatnot that it drove
me into like I gotta try to get laid so
I need extras it's like Wolverine he
needs the claws well it's true and and
developing a sense of humor is something
that can be attractive that you develop
in lieu of being a disgusting monster
yeah like I'm basically notes true Dom
right hunchback yeah yeah you know yeah
not yet but you know I remember the
first time I had a crush on a girl it
must have been I literally kindergarten
and I was being foolish and she giggled
and I remember the first time I made a
girl laugh and I was like I never forgot
it I was like [ __ ] like there's
something to this [ __ ] yeah you know
what happened to me who fee business
when I was graduate from high school I
was a virgin
right me too by the way so thank you
don't be too worried about it I'm not
worried about it at all I'm kidding okay
hey don't don't stress I'm not a lot of
people graduate high school a virgin
right and but I didn't really even get
laid until I was 23 mmm
but I had I had I did some I paid for
some yeah but that's fine I don't feel
bad about it it's fine yeah god bless
you god bless you but at 23 I started
doing stand-up and what happened was I
imagine this and went up on stage one
night it was a Saturday night I hosted
the show at The Comedy Store in La Jolla
and there was a girl in the front row
blonde girl hmm and I said to her she
looks sad because the night Chris
Princess Diana died mm-hmm and she was
sad I go don't be sad about it right I
said that to her and that night she
called the club and said hey where's
that little Asian guy and then I got on
the phone and she goes he want to hang
out and then three days later she lived
with her mom and I was sixty-nining with
her and her mom was that your first sex
act yeah that's right into the race yeah
white white girl a blonde and I couldn't
believe it so there's our ass cheeks
like hey like this and I was going thank
you God
and so that was your impactful and
that's when I know I got to keep doing
this comedy when you were face deep in
vagina you realize yeah yeah and it
changed my life and then I've been like
yeah and I just kept pursuing it would
you say you got in the car me for the
explicit reason of of girls because I've
heard other people say that I wouldn't
that's just say that's true for me but I
know it's true for a lot I don't do it
for the people right I don't give a I
mean I'm I'm happy that people come out
to see me but we sorry we have this
[ __ ] lunatic who shut up YouTube on
the screen let me get her out yeah yeah
yeah that's better that feels better
just a lunatic lunched lurched over us
who was that person it's the girl you've
probably heard that there was a shooter
at headquarters yeah that was her why
did she do it well clear well the reason
is that she thought YouTube was
suppressing her channel but obviously
the real reason is that she was terrain
crazy yeah there's a lot of crazies even
in comedy like in the open mic level you
can just weed them you can see them yeah
people are just delusional
well it's battle of the I mean it really
is battle of the fittest right there are
the open mics oh yeah well you know what
it is is that it opened mics you have
people kids that have the actual talent
right but they're so mixed in with the
crazies that it's a difficult difficult
life to lead you know you have to
somehow you got to somehow get through
it for years and it's really it's really
just depressing really I mean yeah
that's what I've heard from I never went
through the I mean coming up on YouTube
is a whole different yeah what's a
better it's a better it's a better
situation for for kids now I mean you
imagine in the 90s when I started there
was no YouTube there was no Twitter and
you had to just do stand-up with a bunch
of homeless people and like crazy is
like you see it like a transsexual
[ __ ] can I say major
you could say major yeah and they're
alive
same show you are and they're like
what's that man had we're gonna make it
and you're like we're gonna make it
because I'm here do you remember any the
worst like the worst [ __ ] you saw on
stage and those early days what was some
of the worst axes oh my god I mean you
would see a guy like you know come on
walk on stage and you know they're like
oh this is fine and then you look down
their penises out what that's a great
that's a that's a tough act if it's a
tough act phone
yeah yeah penis is hard my I couldn't do
that with mine because mine is um your
dick is gray why I don't like it's not
the skin Cottone of your face no it's no
no no no no it used to be purple
you should be dark you know in MADtv
when I was on that TV they used to call
me black sack black because my sacks
were so dark like a pirate name thank
you but everyone on the cast had seen
your sack enough to nickname it yeah and
that's not good
like Jordan Peele all these guys would
call me black sack
good morning black sack high but so your
sack is dark but as I got older in my
40s my penis looks like a sick alien do
you ever see the movie et yeah Rudy was
sick in the river oh right he was in the
road array yeah so if I pull it out like
flowers will die blows gone yeah that's
that's tough I said huh but you know
what my girlfriend still likes it that's
the most that's that's I'm went on it's
nice yeah to her it's more like the
glowing finger the way yeah yeah there's
barely a glow but you like your penis so
when I was younger when I was like a
young man yeah yeah I I thought I was
like I was proud of it there was a there
was a moment I walk around use can I
call you a Jew you can call me dude yeah
every Jew Jewish person that when I've
seen their penis deep in girthy thank
you yeah well I thought you were
accusing me of having a small dick oh
that's what you're getting no I wasn't
no I wasn't because I've seen Pauly
Shores so many times and it's like you
know
Oh Polly shores strapped oh my god I'd
like a ride at Magic Mountain loop to it
right it's like it does like a it does
like I like this because of years of
just using it in a terrible way
you know I don't have any loops or it's
fine that but every Jude that I've seen
their penis it's been amazing and also
every girl that I've talked to that that
have pen it would you they say that they
really are good in the sack oh that's
nice
I know I just looked at your wife and
you winked that when a wife was sorry
for me
that felt weird yeah cover up there was
a point when I was real proud of my of
my penis but as I've gotten older and
fatter and my balls are droopier like
you get bigger so your dick looks
smaller getting fatter
that's interested in I'm getting work
I'm in worse shape recently and and when
I was a kid I remember thinking like the
day that my balls droop lower than my
dick yes the day that I'm old and I have
to tell you my it's been a long time
since I remember my dick drooping lower
than my balls yeah when it's when it's
like in its sleeping State yeah my balls
look like it's just Asian food it's like
kind of food are gonna dumplings
oh don't blink yes right there yeah like
fried dark you know and they just
they've always is that a thing is that a
Asian thing where the balls are dark
because while your balls so dark yeah
but because like no there's different
colors going on I don't know I'm gonna
beat ya up a little [ __ ] the feel on
it yeah I put like a little tin foil
things underneath no I think that I
don't know why but I think that if you
look at the people can get mad when I
say it what I'm about to say but I think
if you look at asian porn for instance
Japanese porn right you know you did the
the vaginal color of Asian women are
darker purple mm-hmm I know if you
noticed that but I'm sure that's it then
yeah it's it's
life yeah I'm slice yeah yeah so you're
saying so Asians have a little de
genital dark color it'll live and that
doesn't make though it's not your fault
Nasir gonna fault yeah you did it's not
like I'm not gonna blame you for that
don't blame me for something yeah I'm
proud of my daughter sac good yeah yeah
special it's extra wrinkly too is yours
wrinkly man it's like a tangerine dude
it's like one of those tangerines that
like is specially made so that you can
be like whenever a girl sees myself
really wrinkly I go it's because they're
wise I say no an easy peel oh it's an
easy peel yeah easy peel yeah I got I
want to ask you you are notorious I've
seen you on these new shows morning
shows and you get real touchy-feely with
the I can't do that that's what I was
gonna ask you do that now because shits
change well I mean I can't do a lot of
things that I used to do and I and I
I've been touchy-feely with like news
anchors but just guys and girls it's not
just girls and I don't touch there I
just kind of like either kissed her or
I'll touch their knees but just in the
joking way but you can't do that anymore
so I'm very like aware of a lot of
things I can't even squeeze another
comedians ass like a man like Chris
D'Elia the other night you know he is no
you don't know Chris D'Elia if you
pulled up a picture yeah yeah he's hot
I'm bad with names yeah and I um I
squeezed his bun he's like I'm okay with
that he looked at me because I'm okay
with it but don't do that to other
people that's like an intervention that
kind of thinks I kind of feel like
that's him saying I'm not okay with this
he's okay with it
yes yeah he's looking out for you that's
what he was looking yeah he was looking
out for me and because I'm on a new arm
ABC like family showed that like um I've
really been like you gotta be aware yeah
of it I read somewhere that you had
signed some kind of contract with ABC
that you had to tone down your behavior
across them it wasn't that no no I just
been told by my agents that like you
just tone it down yeah and how was that
been for you it's really hard yeah
because everything that I do is and
there's no bad intentions it's I don't
do anything sexually like I don't you
know nothing to do with sex you're
making people uncomfortable as well as
controlling situations
but that's control people in that way
you know feel disappointed it's not that
it's just like I like you know being
naked and stuff right and um but I'm
willing to play get ball play ball so
I've been playing ball and everything's
fine good huh is that while you're
compromising is it been worth it well I
mean at the end of the day I'm in a
dilemma
really because here's the dilemma when I
you know I was on MADtv for so long and
it was a sketch show and I was back in
the day when you could be free and after
MADtv I was sort of I couldn't work
really I just didn't really find that I
was a hot commodity so I did the road
and I did internet stuff and I did a
podcast and I did stuff to rebuild you
know my fan base and I've been I've been
very comfortable in that world you know
I love doing things there's no rules
yeah I love being with you too right now
I feel a kinship and a bond but we're
fellowshiping thank you we are
definitely fellow definitely
fellowshipping yeah no but but then it's
like I look at my friends that do
sitcoms and they do more corporate
entertainment audition yeah and they
make so much money right and so you know
oh you know you're on the internet
internet for a long time and you look at
that you know the glossy like the
billboard and like people you know
smiling you know going eh we're making
money oh I want that
yeah but then not when you're on it it's
a little weird but I'm willing to play
ball try it out I'm trying it out I've
done it before I was on a show called
animal practice it got news about
animals and stuff but um it got
cancelled right away but this one it
looks like it could be on for a little
bit so give it a shot I'm getting walks
I there's nothing I can do I have to do
it yeah you know I need to I need to get
out of my apartment
mm-hmm because I have three dogs two
dogs and three cats
what do you mean have to get out of your
apartment you're saying it's like a
financial thing like no I just have so
many animals when I bought my condo
you're talking about literally you just
need and I wanna be there no no no no
what I need to do is I need to buy a
house
yard right right right because I don't
know if you know this you have how many
dogs do we have one one I Neil oh you
live in a house yes yeah we live in a
condo but its third three levels up so
every four hours at the crown
yeah and it's why we waited so long to
get a dog because before we lived in
apartments our whole life yeah so we
never got a dog because we I knew it
wouldn't be like that
right but a dog is life changes oh my
god it makes the life so much better
yeah it's kind of blowing my mind
yeah it's so shredder the little guy you
know I love sons under the table so it's
he was first time I had I had dogs my
pet and so and and it's my first dog
since I was a kid which doesn't really
count I didn't give a [ __ ] because I was
just a [ __ ] kid but it's like a
magical beautiful it really is
life-changing it is such a sweet
innocent lucky just loves he's just so
sweet like I'll tell you I'll give you
an example now he's he's just got
potty-trained he's good so we had him in
a cage for a long time and now he's out
and free and we have like a tiny little
stairs so he can come up on our bed as
he as he wants to and every night he'll
climb up on the stairs and he'll like
settle next you on the bed he'll crawl
up right up and like nestled on your
neck and just and it's like the sweetest
[ __ ] I have pictures when you were
sleeping last night I don't give a [ __ ]
about the dead air that's gonna like
this is more important but I want to say
talk about my two dogs oh look at that
why do you sleep like that like what I
mean you have all the blankets over your
face you can't like you don't that's how
I comfortable all you do yeah oh wow and
if I can be yeah it can be summer and
I'm like super hot but I have to have
the blanket like all over my she takes
all the [ __ ] blanket and oh I know
it's a meme and it's like everyone jokes
so we used to have a queen-size bed and
like so I was like of course she takes
all the blanket there's nothing so we
got an extra large super massive
king-sized oversized blanket yeah
there's enough blanket for 20 people and
somehow I still have no blanket yeah my
girlfriend things the blanket is a
tortilla and she's like I'm a burrito
yeah you like wrapper way right and then
you're like you know
it's brutal I know it's a jet happens
though cuz I'm just sleeping sometimes
you control it
oh no you know you know what you're
doing and sometimes it trips me up
because sometimes all dare to take a
little more blanket I'll dare and then
I'm like you have enough in you're like
yeah I've funny sounds like you had all
that spare blanket all this time when
you guys fall asleep cuddling or no no
no chance I I can't
no I who can even a even if fingers
touching me I can't sleep I agree I'm
not like a you you just cannot I don't
believe that anyone can fall asleep
cuddling I don't think all day oh yeah
people yeah they may be in love each
other one of the same yeah I don't like
sleep that way maybe feel like a week
yeah
after you've been together for more than
a week if you're still cuddling that
wrist it's not gonna last I give it I
give it come on yeah but Mike you don't
I say this is that and I feel guilty
about this but I love my dogs more than
I love my cousins but they're cousins
no I'm like my cousin my cousins died it
would be devastating but still I'll
still be able to play like Xbox play
like you know Arkwright's five all right
sound that crazy it doesn't right my dog
died Oh out for a year yeah yeah cuz
it's yeah it would be I would like maybe
even I would Eve would you do that what
taxidermy no I feel like that's it when
an animal dies you you put stuff in it
and it's still there I feel like it's
like it would make more ever get over it
right like you're always dredging up the
memory of your of your you have huh what
what what do you mean you have a
taxidermy of a former pet no way do you
do it
mmm no what I would do is clone
happen Barbra Streisand what do you
think about that story how clone but
it's not really the same dog it is close
enough for me
it's close enough is it satisfying I
want to look alike right there but it's
not your I know it's not but it's like
you know it's it looks like it start
over get a new guy there's love there's
love after love love after life yeah but
would it not have certain traits though
similar and might well what she said is
that they have got three right yeah she
said they have different personalities
uh you got I would say like we need to
talk through her to find out yeah we get
like if either one of you passed away
would you clone the other person that's
more weird no I would more also - you
can't do that but oh it's not really an
option I think they can do it I think
they can do what they can if you can do
goats and they can they just don't how
do you think morally it's wrong it's
illegal and I do so let me ask you this
why is it is it because because you're
not because you're basically dooming
this person to a the we're single
strangest most unusual unnatural life
ever and also you don't have to tell
them who can make that decision
what are you that person what just go
just look at your you know like a koala
died and I cloned her right she's a baby
and then right it's your daughter my
daughter and you're getting married I
know but I would never tell her I got
you're actually like my ex-girlfriend
you know my girlfriend why wouldn't you
say where's mommy I go she died mommy I
look exactly like mommy well that's
called genetic and why she said I don't
look like you at all I don't even look
Asian that's true maybe you're right
I think I think it's more of a problem
because I think religious people would
freak out because it ends the idea of
God you know right the idea of like
there's a god you can't really back that
up when we can create our own humans
also the family of that person what
would they think right right but I mean
but like all all moral issues aside yeah
but it's fascinating
it is fascinating and you can clone an
animal but you can't get in their head
like you could talk to a person and
understand yeah what's good if you quit
to Natalie Portman right and snuck up
behind her right and then I snip some
hairs right right and then made 15
Natalie Portman's without her consent
right and you get some sort of sex farm
sure that'd be weird
that'd be fine yeah I think that would
be morally wrong
right but I think that if you know maybe
right I don't know I mean it's it I
wonder if it's inevitable
it isn't ever because it's if it's
possible it's inevitable not only that
right black market will do it when the
black market can do and they can do it
and also real singular oh dude you're
right people are gonna be buying sex
slave Natalie Portman right like one
creepy paparazzi is gonna snip a little
hair yeah that's all you need yeah god
that's twisted that's inevitable wrong
and it's inevitable
you can't wait I told you I would never
do that I have a really good foundation
how much would it cost for a sex slave
Natalie Portman on the black market
million bucks a half a million not
familiar maybe a million yeah maybe even
after a couple years the price goes
downs and you can get her in Walmart
yeah but you know if you got one you
feel so guilty that you'd be like well
you have to be kind of a sociopath to
buy it now I would put it through acting
class all right Jenelle you want her to
be the real deal yeah and then like now
this is the new one right here's
professional - right right [ __ ] I know
it's weird but singularity is gonna
happen you know that I'm all about let
me say might could I see something you
learned and this is the first time we've
ever met
and I don't have a problem with you I
like you a lot but in fact okay but what
you just said there is a little wrong
because I'll tell you why okay if
singularity happens inevitably there's
gonna be a war between man and machine
so what side are you on my friend right
boom yeah that's a toughy because once
well yeah when machines go hey we were
created by man
we're smarter and we could rule the
world so I think Elon Musk
I was just listening to him talking
about incidentally because he is an
alarmist about it he thinks that we need
to be scared about it oh yeah I think
they do I do too actually and there's a
lot of there's a lot of scientists who
oh I think you misunderstood what I said
I mean what I meant is by I'm all about
it is that I'm interested in it oh I see
what I mean I am look the thing is
there's so much potential so the
singularity when you hit that moment of
AI so wanting to people what it is first
doctor the singularity we've talked
about a lot but the singularity is when
super intelligence becomes self-aware
yeah right and then in that moment it's
like what is well what what happens you
know where's Warren West as well
so there's a there's our matrix even
right sure that that's like the ultimate
dystopian vision of it but the reason
we're inventing super intelligence first
of all is incredible because you can
invent the super intelligent being or
intellect not a being and say cure
cancer and it's gonna crunch all the
numbers it's gonna think about it like
no human ever could and in a week
potentially depending on how intelligent
it is it can solve every [ __ ] cancer
every disease yeah and that's what's so
incredible about it the thing that
they're doing is they're building
prisons for it they're trying to build
it in a way with rules and exceptions in
prisons that it can't break out that
this is part of the debate that's going
on it's like can it break out is a novel
that it's gonna break out what happens
when it breaks give within an anarchist
would break into that president right
figure it out you know and connect it to
the world and at that point it's gonna
be it's possible that it already has and
it's already pulling the strings right
Elon Musk could be just an agent of the
super intelligence like it could already
be happening if super intelligence was
on the loose maybe it wouldn't even
reveal itself this master plan is
already in the works
all the strings are being pulled right
now dude billions of people nobody can
crunch numbers on that scale except
super intelligence and it's all this
[ __ ] going on the world with Trump Syria
and Russia it's all the super
intelligent being wiping the way ready
to start anew right
he's poor he's crunching the numbers I'm
telling you dude it could have already
happened luck thanks man
I'll see you out there and doomsday but
that's the truth right it could already
be plugged into the internet maybe I
hate talkin invited because it makes me
feel so helpless like if like I are my
personal brain would be so far behind
whatever is going what everyone's will
be I don't even know I can't even read
you know you know you know the clock
with the little hands read that I have
no idea what time it is right I feel
like if there's no digit all right but
what time is out of it it's this right
right I don't know so imagine that right
I'm definitely gonna be just a pod gun
I'll be in a pod yeah right it's just
you know I'm me pop juice on me yeah any
mistake and make sure to see that bad I
don't know why they were so complaining
about it right like there's that one
scene in matrix where he's like the
steak is dank why would I want to go
back there and it's like that's that's
kind of right and especially I thought
about if I was like neo and I could
manipulate things I'd stay in that world
I guess I call it I just [ __ ] like crazy
all day yeah that matrix 5 yeah it's a
weird one yeah if we were in them like
let me say this let's say we've realized
we were in a matrix would you let him
sex have sex with other people
well what's the difference we're still
our motions are still real right oh
that's true I mean the love is real yeah
the love is real my bad nobody loves me
no no no but would you know I thought
you you know so Elon Musk put it
eloquently by the way just to sum up
this whole thing I like the way he says
it he says it's not that the robots hate
us it's not that they are gonna go out
of their way to destroy us but more like
how we consider an anthill when we're
building a road we don't hate ants but
we have no problem clearing them out so
we can build a road and that's that's
how much that's the scariest thing ever
my wife and I and they're so like a
super intelligent being
Oh far above anything we can understand
yeah that's kind of how they see us
right and now you know what we should
learn from that and not destroy n Hills
right we should go around it yeah let's
send a message yes spare us Wow that's
[ __ ] crazy
yeah it really is it's it's it's real
interesting because it's could as a
potential be the greatest thing that's
the best invention ever yeah and also
the doom of humanity yeah yeah I mean
I'm all into like nanobots like going
inside us and like you know clearing out
sickle-cell anemia if I have it do I do
you think I haven't isn't that I mean I
don't
it's a like black people have it right
you want it yeah what they say I want to
be the friend I get it so sickle-cell
anemia
it's a weirdest and then ever they go
it's only black I go not me and so it's
a weird thing the only black people get
oh yeah it makes you so it's a weird
strange thing it makes you immune to
malaria but it also gives you all kinds
of other words yeah what is it do to you
I don't know I just know that only yeah
I know that African Americans get it so
you are a bug chaser what yeah you know
what that is no bug chasing it just
comes up way too often bug chasing is
somebody who wants to be infected with
the disease specifically HIV why would
anybody want that yeah I guess the
theory is that they want to feel it's a
it's kind of a gay thing and so they
want to feel connected with like more
connected with the community I think
it's like Asians wanting a little dick
so you can connect with the other
exactly you understand yeah exactly
it's not little it's black incidentally
early now black can you here's another
two could I defend the Asian dick thing
though real quick yeah just any because
you know you guys gotta have a lot of
listeners I want to educate people yeah
let us know it's not that we have small
penises okay it's it's your dick is the
same size as your body or proportion of
your body sure so if you look at someone
like Yao Ming it's not like his dick is
like a [ __ ] yeah I mean he's got like a
regular-sized dick for his side which is
like except this yellow little like God
you know I mean it's just you know
stereotype you know whatever but I think
that because I'm
small I'm gonna have I'm not gonna have
a monster dick on this body right that's
all that makes sense
thank you so you're saying that
generally people think the Asians have
small dicks because Jackie that's a
little that's that's a dumb stereotype
because let me see it
Tokyo Drift explain come on what do you
say about Jews Oh what done they say
about Jews what are the stereotypes that
you know about you let's answer those I
feel bad because I don't agree without
give it up I want to hear anyway yes a
mom that you guys are armed with money
great cheap ingredient with money I'll
say of some Jews I know that's true but
I mean but that's also true but yeah I
don't know equally the same amount of
people who are greedy there aren't
Jewish and they always say Koreans or
the Jews of the Orient never heard of
that
I saw what it is no insult right thing
is because why we're hardworking and
we're smart and we can like we know
about finance I've heard it and I
honestly didn't know what it meant
yeah it's surely yes surely it is meant
for but I don't look I've never even
looked at it and I'm like yeah we're
like two because look look okay I want
to defend Korea for a second because
people talk about like North Korea or
Kim Jong moon and I'm tired of when why
people walk out and go hey are you North
or South Koreans it's so [ __ ] stupid
safley is a beautiful place yeah South
Korea is like incredible beautiful place
also look at we're half a peninsula and
I want to defend curry a little bit yeah
what that little we only we don't even
have the full country we have half of
the peninsula and we have Samsung
Hyundai huge corporations for little
half a peninsula we're doing pretty good
were the head of cloning tech technology
great fabrics right great fabrics yeah
so that's where Meryl Streep was at
Meryl Streep I got the cloning of the
dogs whose it was it was uh I wasn't
Meryl Streep it was God I just said her
name
old white yeah a rich lady all right Sam
Barbara did she do it here oh she went
to Korea probably I don't think you can
do that here yeah it's closed I see yeah
yeah yeah no I've been in the
sports I love video games and so I was
playing Starcraft
yeah I've game so well when I got into a
whole like Korean culture was when I was
playing Starcraft 2 Wow and dota wow
you're really into it then dude I have
2,000 hours clocked on dota 2 you do and
about the same on Starcraft 2 you know
what I play
what are you game stardew valley hmm
that's that like farming stardew valley
that's the new one right you making fun
of me no no I played that [ __ ] for like
20 hours of farming yeah that's I'm just
trying to understand it's the one that's
out on switch yes
I played it for 20 hours I enjoyed it
but it was a certain point where I was
like my farm is pretty dope
no it wasn't dumb enough well that's the
beauty of the bug no maybe why it's so
amazing okay until you get the golden
clock ain't no the golden cry yes you
don't even know about that what is the
gold clock do for you this guy Eric
brony developed his game called stardew
valley i'm just gonna start from the top
from the top you know he was by himself
he was it had a wife who work he didn't
work and he just in his apartment he
lived in Seattle and he created his own
independent game you know called stardew
valley it was based on because he had
this obsession with Harvest Moon right
we're growing up so basically what it is
is that it's not just a some farming
simulation game you can go in the mind
you fight a monster I did do that and I
loved it right you can fish as well you
can fish really yeah you can fish
unbelievable yeah and it's not just
fishing though - it's like you could
there's legendary fish you can catch and
whatnot but here's the thing about it is
it there's a wizard in the forest you
know that the wizard in the forest Ryan
countered it and once you have a
relationship with him there's story
lines with him and then eventually you
can buy things from him and one of the
things that you can buy from it and the
most expensive thing is a golden clock I
was gonna guess yeah thank you and what
you do with the golden clock is it's ten
million dollars so it's I know if you
have to grind hard alright but when you
get it it's great because you put it on
your form and there's no more debris no
more debris that's like oh so I know it
debris is it when the [ __ ] grows and all
that
it saves you a bunch of time let me
guess you got that clock Daniel
there's no [ __ ] memory on your farm
another way debris less it makes me want
to try the game I think you would like
it I think you would love it and let me
say something it's grinding but it's the
fun kind of grinding where there's
always goals like I need to make truffle
oil right or it's like I need that
there's this thing called rare seed I
need a harvest more rare seat so I can
make more money and whatnot so there's a
lot to do and I just really enjoy it I
wanted to love it I want I put in 20
hours I wanted to love it but something
just held me back I think in general in
the past five years I found myself
enjoying videogames less really because
I have this feeling that I should be
doing something else and it ruins the
games for me and it's awful you don't
know let me say something to you mine I
didn't always have that and that's how a
club that's our dice know you manifest
things in your life you know that right
tell me more I need help dude what else
I'm gonna tell you a little story about
me a friend yeah if you ask any comedian
I'm the laziest of them all I don't
write mm-hmm you know I don't eat well
mm-hmm you know I'm I'm on the border of
death I think I am you're rotting right
now yeah from the feed off yeah I don't
exercise
I don't shower I don't do much okay but
a lot of good things have happened in my
life do you know why why is that
visualize I can't and I believe and you
don't believe you have nothing you were
just saying before we went on that you
were in a little fender-bender and you
were visualizing your way out of it
right yeah I do that a lot I try to
think positive thoughts
right and things the outcome of things
are gonna be great for me how do you
explain that I'm gonna explain it you
really like visualize what it would be
like what it is that you want yeah I'll
give you an example
okay on Barham Boulevard all right if
you go around that bend you drive by
Warner Brothers Studio mm-hmm and in
Warner Brothers Studio they have these
gigantic billboards of their shows okay
so it's like and
every time I draw a bond there I would
be haunted by like you know these
posters and in my head I'm like I want
to be on a Warner Brothers show haunted
because you want it to be because it was
all my friends were on it right I'm like
oh so I wanted to be on a billboard
there right so that can cause my enemies
pain right no that's the only reason why
to be a you want to be grinning up there
on I want like I have a lot of enemies
I'd like ten of them yeah yeah and I
want them to be stuck in traffic there
and then see my billboard there I like
me on a bill or inning and yeah and
going and to cause them right what do I
try to visualize my do you visualize
them suffering or you on the Billboard
sounds positive it's revenge in a
spiritual way hello right right instead
then what happened was I got on a I
don't know if I would have my hat
there's no billboard there yet but it
could happen
I don't know way of a Warner but I'm on
a Warner Brothers show that they own and
and guess how that show happened how so
okay listen they called an even audition
they just called me one day and they go
do you want to be on this one they
offered you this there and I go yeah I
knew this was gonna happen it's
happening my grants my plan is happening
if you tell them that yeah they're like
yeah yeah they're like okay and then I
did the table read I did the pilot I got
picked up and now it's on so let me let
me Congrats but yeah first of all
congratulate you thank you that's great
thank you thank you so do you meditate
on this like how does the visualization
take well it's linked stardew valley you
suppose yeah yeah you know I know
because you know when pumpkins are
growing you know how pumpkins grow you
know my planet go in the game the game
you plant you sleep you go in you come
out they grow a little bit ERI right so
what I'm watching else sometimes does
watch the screen and just stare at my
pumpkin patches I got it you're gonna
look
of it it sounds almost like more
meditative than I mean as much
meditative as gayness you sort out all
your issues yeah I wouldn't have
visualized like because are like little
pixelated characters but I also
visualize a little sexual things with
the people in the village it's great is
there a billboard of you on WB and other
villages yes but um so sometimes I'll go
ugly playing it and I'll just be just
looking at my farm and I'll visualize
things you know so that's so but no but
so do you do you just hold on to the
image or do you think about like things
happening you know I mean I'm half
joking because I'll be this is the real
cause I know okay I'm gonna tell you the
honest truth
okay and then because I don't want
people to think I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ]
all right the honest truth is this is
that yes I'm lazy right
but I also blue there is a blue there is
a thing that I do where I believe that
things are gonna happen for me it's
believed yes I just I just believe it
yeah and then you know I'll still show
up to auditions and I'll show up to
things and I don't stress about stress
out about things and things just kind of
they happen you know and it's because
I've always been like that I think in
retrospect where I just kind of why
would you why would I continue to do
something horrible like open mics for
like seven eight years of struggling if
I didn't believe that something was
gonna happen
yeah and I think the same with you you
do it I think that this podcast is
something that you manifested so you do
it as well yeah yeah no I I relate to
that and I think that I think you
manifested her look what a beautiful
wife she's bright she's foreign she's
got exotic well tendencies you know I
love it yeah I guess I don't know I mean
I don't know I I worked my ass off for
this one yeah yeah but in the work
I like this what are we talking about
her leg what did he do well I just
didn't I proceeded I didn't think it
wouldn't it would be an option for me
because I was in Israel and it was
hearing right so I was like you even
think about even think of
and then what happened for him to sway
you
he kept and like we started talking on
skype but it was it was just very I
don't know persistent I don't know but I
keep going and going yeah it's just like
see when you know you and I think
there's a had a no yeah a lot of moments
to just give up mmm-hmm
so I did have a feeling of like
rightness in it I don't know what this
means what does this mean something but
there was a reason that I pursued it you
know because when you meet because
people aren't like snowflakes there are
all individuals right and when you see
the snowflake of your heart right I say
that you're absolutely right about the
summer suit that snowflake with all your
mind and your energy when I match with
kalila on tinder
I liked her legs and I liked her
eyeballs really yeah
that's it and when I met her face to
face we sat out a coffee shop I go this
is gonna be it I can feel it I need to
really loose you how long you guys been
together five years oh my god god bless
you don't listen to you know a lot of
times it's just I'm just staring it yeah
I like your eyebrows you do thick and
thin at the same time thank you for that
that's out I don't know I guess there's
a lot to visualizing that I think is
true where it sounds kind of weird at
first but when you think about it it's
just really being focused on something
yeah because I was always true yeah and
I was always a negative guy like I you
know I've been to war Reap drug rehabs
and I've been struggling with drug
addiction and when I was younger I was
suicidal and and then I think when I got
sober in my early 20s I mean I got my
teens my late teens and I stayed sober I
realized that there's gotta be something
to this like cuz my life right now is
just so dark and negative and I might
pay money and I have no dreams that I
just shifted my mental you know the way
I perceive
hmm how do I do that how did you
accomplish something and that's that's a
feat well I think I because you know
that there's a thing in like if you're
at 12-step groups people think
everything you know cuz you believe in
this concept of God right so then you
kind of think um you know you know you
know there's a step in it the third step
was you turn your life and your will
over the care of God
right so you practice that at first
right you go and so in your head if you
think that there is this loving God not
Jesus I don't believe in Jesus but you
believe that there's this entity and
energy that wants good things then you
have to use it so I think that's when I
started like really kind of going you
know what I'm gonna try this thing of
like praying and also I was at in a
meeting once and this old man came up to
me and there's this place called North
Park men's meeting was on a Friday night
and I went and I spoke at this thing
right and then afterwards this old man I
never saw him before or after this he
got a kid there's something about you
you should do comedy really yeah I go
what and that was the catalyst and I got
guys you should just tried to do some
sort of hammer tonight or something he
pulled me aside to say there's something
right and in my head you could look at
that incident and go oh it's just some
random old crazy man or the way I looked
at it was this is some sort of sign just
a sign so an unbelievable unbelievable
thing happened I was working at a coffee
shop this is like four or five months
after I ran into this man and the coffee
shop closed but right next door was a
comedy club hmm and I went next door to
get a you know there was a Help Wanted
sign another vine in my head it could be
just a random coincidence right but I
don't look at it that way something so I
knocked on the door and this guy I
answering that why do you want it was
like the manager of the club like oh
there's a sign you know that says that
you need the bar back all right
you're the guy from next door I go yeah
you go alright and then I saw open and
then I was washing dishes and I said the
open mic night one night and I want you
know I want to try it
mmm right so everything
remember that one yeah what I'm saying
is is that you could look at life as a
series of coincidences and you know but
I don't look at life like that I believe
that you and I us three were meant to be
here at this moment Wow and we're here
to get I really do believe that and
that's why I'm here and that's why I'm
enjoying myself me too by the way
god bless you god bless you that's a
great story I love that yeah so you know
I think that's like grace I don't know
it's like it's a beautiful thing you
know when things like that like I'll do
even one that last example of it there
was this woman well I was working in the
back door at the comedy show I was a
doorman in the Hollywood and I was broke
and I was I was checking IDs and there
was a lady there her name was Ann and
she would look confused and I go can I
help you she's like I hate this club I
don't know how to get in this club and I
go what's your name she goes my name is
Ann and I go you know what I'm gonna
sneak you in the back I snuck her in I
bought her a glass of wine that I I
don't know why but I just want to be
nice to another human being and she goes
at the end of the night she goes hi I'm
an agent and I go yeah but that's not
what happened what NH goes but anyway my
name is Ann and what's your name my name
is Bobby Lee she's your comedian I go
yeah and then when I tested for MADtv
she was an executive there what and she
remembered you know I don't know if that
has anything to do with it this than
that but in her in my head it's all
connected in that way you know that's
really and now probably all of your
listeners are probably thinking that I'm
a frog though and then I'm a deceiver
and I live in black magic but I don't I
believe that what I'm saying if there is
some sort of foundation and truth to it
so when you think of God how do you
imagine that being that that gave you
the grace to I can't believe that I
cannot believe that like Catholicism or
Judaism or they all have separate gods I
have to believe that at the end of the
day it's all one thing all right and
people are just calling it a different
thing I think that I don't know what it
is
I don't I don't I don't have a religious
doctrine that I read like the Bible or
the you know or the Book of Mormon or
you know when you pray do you speak to
some no I just I just kind of go I just
believe in some I'm this an energy
that's positive and that wants pretty
much good customer mean I like that yeah
but completely wrong what does it matter
yeah what's what's right around you I
really do believe it and I'm not
changing my belief okay I really love
the idea of not like a gut like I've
always found the idea of like thick the
it's more abstract it's not like a
character yeah I love what you say yeah
I've always found the idea of like a god
who's just like perched up in the sky
like jerking off and [ __ ] throwing
lightning he doesn't do that he probably
probably does that's weird
well he's all about [ __ ] would be
jerking off where's Neville the devil I
mean what does he Natalie Portman is
Natalie Portman yeah he's a guy it was
created in His image he created a woman
from his own rib so that he could [ __ ]
it okay anyway the point is I've always
found that idea I'll be fine for a while
yeah you'll be fine but that even jokes
like that I'm fine with because the
thing is I don't believe in that
religious right what I yeah yeah the my
point is that this guy who's like
judging you and think yeah it was just
it seems how can you go through your
life living that there's some guy who's
just like judging everything you do like
I kind of did cuz I grew up a little
Orthodox in a way yeah and I really my
only feeling about it now is just how
stupid it is cuz it just plants this
fear in you all the time what am I doing
wrong today really like you oh [ __ ] I a
dairy after I ate meat
God is not gonna forgive me you had
thoughts like that yeah at one plant
there's like you gotta wait six hours
according to some people but some people
will wait three hours and then some
people will only wait one hour yeah but
but it's that nitpick it's like what's
the why would he care if I waited six
hours or three hours yeah and at that
point why does he care at all and right
the biblical God is such a vain
like insecure weirdo yeah but it's like
why would I even want to please this
[ __ ] lunatic yeah I don't why would
he create like also it's like the whole
like the gay thing in Judaism is are
gays persecuted or are they accepted I
don't think they're accepting yeah well
so there's different tiers like in
Israel there's like it's all good to be
gay but the Orthodox don't like the
games right yeah yeah I just
all that's that all that negative like
we it's weird it's like you know it's
like I I can't I can't buy it and I
can't live by it yeah I just love all I
think you know but I love the idea of
just like a positive force that like
wants good and just acknowledging yeah I
could be delusional and I could be wrong
but I will not change you know and don't
get mad I get suicidally depressed do
you oh yeah yeah I'll wake up and go oh
my god here's life again mmm and all
this weight and this hole in my gut and
I can feel like you know an am penis
right but I have to do things right - I
can't just stay in that right right I
have to do things like I'll try to help
somebody or I'm like you know that's
another thing is is that and this is
gonna sound crazy but I believe that the
root of happiness is to get out of
yourself mmm and to help another health
fellow human being and in the way I do
it is I do it in the business of comedy
I you know I don't want to I have a lot
of character defects and I'm not the
perfect human being but the one thing
that I am good at is I've helped a lot
of comics hmm like if a comic needs to
get an agent I'll try to help more they
want to try to get into a club I'll try
to help you know I've had a couple of
friends that were really good comics
that wanted to be at the agency I meant
I'll call the agency and go and you
really have to sign these two guys you
know so you know I do things I feel like
to try to help people I don't think that
you know here's what I here's that thing
that I have to get over and this is
something that
I have helped a couple skies and they
just would never help me back and then I
get kind of resentful and I have to get
then older that I have to realize that
was a pure act the first bit at is pure
and I can't I can't do the act right do
you expect something in return
right and that's difficult you have to
be be like I'm lightened you know but
there are large [ __ ] out there I just
want to get this off my chest right
where I've there's a couple of people
where I've loaned a lot of money to it
really big names and they won't pay me
back who are like huge war on billboards
yes but just FYI you know I gave you the
money just because I love you you want
to drop a blog just took blood no no no
they know it's causes it'll cause a war
they know though they know who they are
they don't know who they are oh they
don't even know who they are yeah yeah
have you ever been like okay cuz if
you're upset at someone you owe it to
them in a way to be like hey I just
won't let you know that I have all this
hatred in my heart I've played video
games and I fantasize about you being
stuck I thought you know what do I think
I would do that if I needed the money
okay if I if I love but it's not about
the money right and what about that
principle but here's the thing is is
that how much money are we talking about
can I ask that a couple grand okay yeah
enough that it's like what the [ __ ]
you're a millionaire no we're top right
yeah yeah yeah like there's one person
there killing it I'm gonna even say with
the gym I'm gonna write don't even ask
that
it's a female obviously if you would say
that don't ask a gender because
obviously what are you across all right
it's a [ __ ] guy okay all right cuz
this dude
yeah right right this dude is killing it
right and if I was broke right I would
walk up to this guy yeah and go hey
rumor I help him here and then put that
a bunch of times I'm really not doing
well I kind of need the money back but
because I'm fine and I'm killing it that
I'm just willing to eat it and just you
know if they want to go here's the money
back I'll even go like this you know
what I don't even want a bad yeah I just
want but they're games for even offering
to pay that
I wonder if they think in their mind
they're like Bobby Lee is killing it
he's giving this to me as a gift as as
he's just trying to help me out
or what's the pretense like you got to
pay me back when you're good for it
because it's Paula yeah yeah if that
wasn't clear so in that way also you're
right it's tough yeah it's tough it's
fine I'm [ __ ] okay but so do you feel
like maybe they still appreciate that
gesture and now that they're like on
Billboard's well do they stare the usual
where one time yeah and I'm not gonna
name the guy don't is it a guy yeah sure
I can even give you that information
I believe you own this this [ __ ]
yeah I'm going to tell you there's a
couple of guys I'm gonna get my
grievances out I love it yeah I want to
hear about this is one guy right I would
see his first name okay John okay
interesting okay his name is John were
quote jay-z from America okay I was in
America okay so he knows into Mid
America he knows Mid America right what
state
what's his life oh hi oh I'm not there
for John from Ohio this guy right was an
open mic car yeah all right
and one day he he had no money and one
day this years ago he said I need I want
to take acting classes but I have no
money
right and I go you know what you want an
acting classes you're a good guy and
you're very talented I will pay for
those acting classes and this
[ __ ] became famous hmm okay mmm
and one day I'm walking by him at the
comedy club
you guys parted ways no but you know
just moved on ya know you know you need
it and we were still friends okay okay
but one day he goes and let me tell you
something this is years after it right
and he never paid me back it's fine I'm
fine over it and I was fine with it but
then he goes I don't let you know you're
not a real comedian
Wow I go what and he goes yeah you're
just a guy that was on TV and got lucky
and now you get spots mm-hm I walk by
him and I wanted to gouge his eyes out
but why would ya I don't know but he
became or did they likes coccyx here's
what some people when they when they
struggle and then they finally make it
they've become like Joffrey King jockey
from it could be that he you know he
hated everyone
the whole time but he was using them so
he had to put on a face that's what it
is no resolve was hidden right and then
they said finally get a position real
power and freedom and they just start
lashing out right
I don't like dudes like that it's all
right John from middle of America who is
that I'm gonna tell you I'll tell you
afterwards I want to start a war it's
awful anyone know I don't want to start
a war I gave you enough clues right not
to start a war but still there's a
little bit of interest out there right
you know these things you know that he
is name is John right you know that he's
from Mid America right you know he's a
comedian right and that's all it's done
that's all you get all right those are
the clues okay I'm not sorry okay here's
another one
I'm waiting one last one yeah okay and
this one I can even get more specific
okay all right yeah his name was Kevin
right he's okay
age I mean can I say it's eight years in
EndNote 8 what you're saying some kind
of agent thing right I didn't say that
but and I helped him out and he betrayed
me your wife is like the is is that's it
okay
but your name's Kevin and United he
betray you you know what's a betrayal
well he pushed me at a comedy club
pushed yeah he was drunk and he walked
up to me I was at a table with some
friends and this is what he said to me
he goes look at you and go what he goes
you know dr. ken Jeong he's doing so
much better than you how does it feel to
not be a star anymore right she was
drunk I said what's wrong with why
what's with all these Psychopaths
I know so then what you know what I
walked up to him at the improv and I go
why did you say that to me buddy you
know and he pushed me he shoved you yeah
but Kevin and he has this right and he's
a comedian okay that's all that's all
I'm gonna say that's enough information
I feel like to identify somebody that's
not enough I just start some Wars I
don't know
I'm sweating now
you were sweating before you know these
two characters you know me want to have
a little coffee with me and we could
just smooth it out mm-hmm
I'd be willing to do that mm-hmm that's
great but okay so if I can't air I feel
like to get to the point where you're
willing to shove somebody I feel like
you did you not do any offense to this
guy well here's the offense yeah I feel
like you're not you're leaving something
out okay I want to tell you what yeah
what yeah I did a tour with him yeah
okay
I'm yep I'm not gonna name the tour okay
right and at that time the people that
were on the tour I was the only name on
the tour mm-hmm cuz I had you've been on
MADtv for so long right and so they paid
me more but it was a four man tour
mm-hmm but you were the headline no we
were all people equal in it but but man
any more money because I was at that
time the draw you okay fair enough
okay yeah and apparently some people got
resentment that I got 60% of the money
it's a lot I should take less and I mean
what I feel guilty I feel guilty for
taking so much money and in retrospect
if you know I would do it over again I
would take away less and I apologize
this is like mad but don't push me yeah
at a comedy club and humiliate me in
front of people sure it's all I'm saying
Kevin if you're out there this is worth
doing that Kevin his name is that
whatever but if you're whatever cat yeah
whatever it was Kevin but fine whoever's
out there who knows who you are
yeah we're mending bridges here I'm what
about that first one what was there an
offense in the first case as well
no he just went on like a lunatic yeah
okay and I don't know if that
relationship will ever mend because um
well I mean there's no turning back dog
once I leave I think he needs to go
potty
yeah such a cutie pie he said cute dog
he's the best what kind is that
Yorkshire yeah carry on
Yorkie yeah yeah
oh you didn't want to he doesn't want to
leave us though but he doesn't want to
leave he just won't leave us because
he's such a sweetie I think you gotta
take him outside um dad reveal too much
on this podcast I feel like I don't know
something about powerful know something
about utility change that makes me want
to just keep I feel like something
beautiful well I think that you revealed
stuff but you also took blame where you
need it right you've been through some
[ __ ] man you know yeah you know what
here's the thing at the end of the day
okay at the end of the day and this is
something that other comedians should
hear me say is is that you you can't be
loved not everyone's gonna love you
that's that's not everyone's gonna love
you yeah and you know Mitzi shore you
know that is I'm sorry I'm sorry so the
Comedy Store is owned by Mitzi shore
Pauly Shore is mine
oh and in this you know they did a movie
they're doing a TV show they're called
I'm dying up here it's about pretty much
mid say ah but back in the day when I
was living in San Diego um I knew mid
said she's still alive but she's she's
lost her mind sure but you know we
should drive her around I've had dinner
with her a bunch of times and one night
she looked at me and just when she was
coherent and clear and she looked at me
and she said you wanna you know what
makes a star I go what half the people
have to love you but equally half the
people have to hate you at the same time
mm-hmm and I go wow that's interesting
look at Roseanne people went on her dead
but people loved her because eat both
things causes one causes controversy but
you want people to just to talk about
you so I'm in Maine yeah and you know so
in there's only a few people if you
think about it there are completely
beloved only I think Tom Hanks yeah
here's one guy he's a rare entity where
people but look you look at someone like
Jim Carrey right
he's so polarized these days especially
right always true no I think even before
his he was so bra
so hammy that some people don't like
that Cosmo comedy when you say that one
of my idols or and even our inspiration
for the show is Howard Stern yeah and he
was like hated passionately but that's
what you need I think to become a real
star it's so hard to accept it though
like the hate the hate comment well last
week my you Tuesday night my [ __ ]
show air a second time right and some
guy tweeted at me you're the worst actor
you should be recast right mm-hmm and
that destroyed me it's and it's just
some [ __ ] it's some kid on my yearly
almost never left the house again right
I laid in bed and kalila was out of town
so I had to just week I was reading it
on my own and it closed my eyes and so
in those moments it's hard to manifest
positive thinking I get paranoid
I'm terrible right you know I should
kill myself right but then you you
called a couple of people and then they
straighten it out you know you're
talking you call your friends does this
happen to you it happens to me I find
I'm and I'm trying to break this cycle
because it's so sick like I'll get a
hundred really like passionate loving
yeah wonderful encouraging comments yeah
and then one guy that says something
like that and that's the one that you
don't forget yeah our cuz you know what
it is they're there they're banging on
your own paranoid fears about yourself
right and then because you're almost
looking for someone to verify your own
fear yeah that's what it is and you're
like I knew it even though everyone's
like I loved I loved you and yeah I knew
it
I'll do a show on the road and I'll kill
but I'll walk off and go I just ate it
and they'll go why you killed I know but
that lady
that one night sitting there you know
and she doesn't like me because I see no
I showed my pubic hair right religiously
she doesn't you know she didn't face
boobs yeah yeah I have straight pubes
that weird I don't think they don't curl
it's not what I mean Asians have
straight hair that is true it's a fact
but because if they don't currently it's
constantly scared you should bleach your
tips
that's so good like that one chef gaya
died fury yeah half year fit guy fury
Maidan you should do that his mine it's
just a curly I mean it's almost like a
desirable zone no it's not it's like a
chia pet I mean I'm not kidding and it's
awful it's swampy too you have a swampy
dick well not the dick itself but like
all the air it dick emerges from Raya
it's like a beautiful tree coming out of
a swamp
yes you know there's a beautiful white
noise yeah like a reverse away right
right
I just curly as well well it's not a
surprise all right come on don't try to
dip oh that's that's all I ask you ask
come on give me a break no I'm kidding
I'm kidding I'm kidding asking me what
my girlfriend I don't want I don't want
to Bobby I'm kid having friend ok good
Rio it's like a flower dad I'm just
kidding I don't yeah don't eat anything
something that there's there's you know
I love vaginas I do and I love the way
they look it look like life comes from
there that's true right it did says true
but there's some style I don't like mhm
and so when I first met my girlfriend
like please don't have the styles of
vagina because I liked her and I would
have to just accept whatever she had
down there mmm she probably in her head
thought I don't want to et dick mm-hmm
but she got she got yeah she got that
yeah you got [ __ ] I mean but I don't
like um jazz hands a China what is jazz
hand with a butler that lipstick got
like that and they did a little number
oh I know well okay well I'm not asking
well that I call I want it I think the
technical game is the like the voles
[Music]
there's there's a part word they contain
cool right yeah you know I saw a
documentary about young girls and the UK
who were getting
surgeries to get that [ __ ] removed guys
like me that I should never
say that out loud whenever you have made
that and it's good look it's whatever
yeah yeah we're all got we all got our
problems but the last point I want to
make is here's another thing what I
don't like about the PC and things and
people getting in trouble for is is that
you can it's like people are so
sensitive now yeah that you can't say
certain things I can't be authentic you
can't be honest there's no help there
right I'm constantly filtering myself
and let's just let's be ourselves like
let's not filter ourselves like
sometimes you filter yourself yeah cuz I
refuse you know how little people little
beauty that was insensitive yeah I'm
gonna call the midgets midgets yeah
that's the one thing I bet you won't
compromise I don't know how can I can I
tell you about my about that one day
what's the difference what's the
difference yeah I know I was like I
don't know just here's what my
experience was that was I grew up my
whole life and we were calling a midgets
and there was no there was no
implication of life right but one day I
called him someone a [ __ ] and they and
I get like blowback and so I'm like I
didn't know what happened the world went
on without me I made something for like
six months they says they want to be
called little people now yeah and I and
I am think to myself that sounds more
that sounds more demeaning would your
little guy yeah yeah yeah I wouldn't be
one of that are ya little guy yeah just
a little person there it's like okay
don't call me Oreo don't call me yellow
people yellow people would yeah yeah but
like it's also what I was saying is it's
all about the intention right and it's
so obvious what someone's intention is
if it's ill-will or if it's just being
I'll tell you the difference or if
you're just being rough on the edges
right it's like oh look at that cute
little [ __ ] or let's hang that [ __ ]
the intentions are do cute little
midgets a little rough Peter Dinklage
okay
you don't need to introduce him as a
mess
yeah the guy all right the guy that
works at Chuck E Cheese in a [ __ ] what
wait yeah that's for that better or what
you act are you talking about the [ __ ]
yeah yeah I like the guy in Game of
Thrones which one the [ __ ] yeah that's
fine
it sounds weird but it should be yeah it
sounds weird you know what I love that
anymore
the little reason does that sound better
who watch which portion on Game of
Thrones do you like the little person
that's weird yeah yeah yeah let's stick
with [ __ ] yeah I don't know I guess
yeah yeah you're right we're discovering
we're learning at the same time I want
to feel what it's like yeah we're
exploring the point is that you can get
a little bit offended and it's fine and
you can move on and people can make fun
of you a little bit yeah like I don't
like how you you have to walk on eggs so
much these days cuz everything could
like ruin your career
yeah that's the part that's the scary
part it's not just like you offended me
sir and I demand apology it's like you
offend him I'm going to contact telling
all my friends I'm telling all your
sponsors I'm coming to your house I mean
you have no idea what happened to me I
don't know if I something happened to me
what happened yeah I'm gonna say it but
I said something I don't think that was
that offensive what was it we have to
know what it all right all right say
everybody you know yeah but but now okay
I and I okay I'll go gay I'll tell you I
think it's alright alright yeah I don't
think I should say okay yeah okay
because because you know because what
happened was I'll tell you what I said
what happened was I was taught I was do
I have my own podcast yeah Agri ballet
yeah Bush and I did a whole episode on
Asians and we talked about all the
definitions then we didn't want episode
about Mexicans I said one thing about
black people right and then I got an
email saying that if you I'm gonna blast
you to us Entertainment Weekly and all
these magazines if you don't give me 15
grand
really yeah were they in a position to
do that
who was it was it some
random person on the email I don't know
and then they try to extort me for money
right and then all of a sudden and in my
head because of the climate I thought in
my crazy head give this person 15 grand
oh right so that you know and then I
showed up I got a commercial like a
pretty big commercial and when I was
sitting there one of the a lawyer or
something came up to me at the
commercial and said did you say this
about right and this person contacted
them it was the same person yes
so my point is is that it this whole
environment there is a gradient no okay
that's good no because they you know
people vent you you know and and this
adage they vetted me they know what I'm
about and and that's scary too oh it's
so scary and you want you once you're
like got that one blemish it's like
vetted and out yeah and it's like I
don't like any chances I don't know what
happened to our society I'll give you
another example I have a bit about how I
was molested by a guy with Down syndrome
I've heard is it a bit it's joke I do on
stage but it's real right yeah it's
interesting that it's a dare you defer
as a bit almost because it makes it but
I did it and I did it once I was in on
the road and some guy in the front row
mm-hmm I I'm not making fun of people
I'm just saying the designer happened to
have down syndrome blessed me right and
he's and he went out of his mind but he
didn't molest me weird if he did because
your son is probably young and this
happened what make sense yeah why why
would he be there why would your son
there yeah it's insane yeah yeah so it's
like people just get so sensitive and
but the thing is I know yeah what can
you do I don't know it's funny cuz louis
c.k was like the champion of like and he
had this incredible ability to Galant
stage and say the most obscene things
but he get it he pulled on me and then
he starts and then he shows dick there
one no he
I can't even get into there it was he
was the he was the chosen one who's
bringing balance to the force
I know but by the way I that's why I
really love humanity wouldn't Ricky
Gervais is really good it's all about
that same with Dave Chappelle's to see
his looks it's about that job yeah yeah
which is it real hard yeah it I think
that's just what it's you you're not an
American if you can't talk and opinion
yeah that's what life I mean that's the
it's a freedom that's what American
writers and you may not like what I'm
saying but it's like you know I don't
but even me I don't get offended you
know if some you know like this guy
named Andrew Santino right he's a comic
he's very popular and I make fun of him
cuz he has red hair and I think they're
weird people with red hair
so I also when I bring him up on stage
in front of a packed room I'll go my
redheaded friend that's weird that you
know they're like mutants or whatever I
might say and the he comes up on stage
and does this meaning does that and it
crushes I'm not offended by it because
it's it's not coming from hatred yeah
you know we're just having fun here guys
but yeah and even if it does come from
hatred just as long as well yeah okay
that's why it's feel your freedom to say
it is what I was getting yeah but like a
fourth baby you harm somebody physically
or something livelihood away that's
that's not right no different yeah you
know it's funny in a way because people
choose to go after good people we just
said something it's the bad people are
doing stuff its way the people who
actually do shitty stuff from a bad
place do are the ones that get second
chance Chris Brown beat the [ __ ] out of
Rihanna and he's still [ __ ] shaking
his dick on MTV
yeah and selling albums but and like Mel
Gibson I mean I don't know what's in
that guy's head but he went on a an
actual anti-semitic rant yeah but it
hurry he'll never shake that he won't
shake it I guess she just embraced it at
that point yeah I won't say that that he
got off on that one he didn't get off on
I think that it's he used to be an
a-list movie star oh I'm a huge fan of
his
I think Braveheart is amazing I love
I've seen that Booga house I love I love
him yeah my favorite is out an amazing
he was actually my favorite actor I mean
he's he's great but so you're not
offended he said that so the thing is
like it it's eyebrow-raising
what he said yeah but it's not gonna
[ __ ] ruin my day
yeah because he's not talking to me yeah
I'm talking about you I don't take I
don't take Jew jokes personally I take
comments about me sometimes I take
homeless personally but not the stuff
about like oh he's a Jew
yeah it's more like you know yeah good
job dude
nice work there on that one yeah cuz you
know you know my favorite Jews another
thing I'm on your favorite juice Wow top
ten doctor what you know a thousand oh
that's what I mean there's everywhere
every one area you throw a stone in LA
your head to five Jews he's we did you
throw a penny in LA five just what I
want my reps to be Jewish
cuz there's Jewish and I love it does he
bar mitzvah chi-chi bar/bat Mitzvah no
she's not active
you should have active Jew but she is
Jewish hmm but she like giving example
like she I did this when I was a long
time ago did this commercial and I don't
know if this is I'm getting in trouble
for saying this but um they offered me
$75,000 it was like a buyout hmm and she
got me $350,000 in for our period give
me your [ __ ] and she just was able to
do it and I have and does that have to
do with her being Jewish 100% it comes
from the Torah there's a secret so you
know most people think that we're just
looking at the Torah and reading it yeah
but if you hold a black light up my die
now yeah because I'll be found with
weird nerve agent may you have to let
you go
you're fine mom out the mill listen it's
been two hours
no yeah we've been on for two hours it's
been it's been a romp it's
a riot has been a joy and a pleasure
it's been chemistry I thought that that
we were like war buddies yeah we've been
through
absolutely and we'll see each other at
those like PTSD meetings you know it was
really a pleasure to meet you I want to
ask you one question
go ahead cuz we ask all of our guests
this and first of all it may it plug
some things before oh yeah of course I
would do that right now yes so that you
give me the opportunity to do so of
course let's do it
I have a podcast with my girlfriend it's
called tiger belly we would love to have
you guys on that as well yes we're there
and number two I have a sitcom on
Tuesday nights it's after Roseanne it's
called splitting up together that's a
good spot and it's doing pretty good so
uh check that out guys nice so where can
your well better be
when is this air of this podcast
tomorrow tomorrow I want to be at the
Denver Comedy Works next weekend cool
I'll put is there like a ticket link you
can send us we'll put it on to do that
anyway guys please support Bobbie Lee
and all the the podcast is great Bobby
Lee live on all my social media there
you have it so what are you gonna ask me
something friend so um if you don't have
an answer
that's fine I have I don't have one but
it's customary that we ask our guests if
they have any ghost stories or
paranormal Albert oh yeah ghosts or UFO
encounter unexplainable [ __ ] whatever
you got well my brother and I have
talked about this because my brother has
his own YouTube channel or whatnot
well this TV we be show and my brother
and I grew up in a town called Poway
California
what's going on with water sir okay I'm
parched
and we know that half of our house was
on some sort of Indian burial site
that's his because my brother and I
would hear demons we see demon
collectively you would both hear the
same thing and what my dad said later in
life was um he'd said he said tell us
one day goes I I don't believe in the
ghost but every time I park my car after
work I run through the hallway because I
feel weird he felt
but that's where my brother and I is
bedroom bedrooms were in the bathroom
but my dad would run past our bedroom
used to see your own dad running yeah
because of the fact that he felt an evil
presence there in fact one day I thought
I was possessed and for me to get out of
it I jumped into the swimming pool yeah
we had a swimming pool we did pretty
good unless killer but yeah but enough
to get an unwanted house
yeah then when we moved out and it
stopped but my brother and I were both
possessed several times we thought I did
you know you're good we fell a demon
like like we would hear things and we
were times when we would like be asleep
and awake and we couldn't move we felt
this presence and it's never happened
after we humped out of a window into the
pool no no it was we had one floor okay
but I would run out of my bedroom one
time and I [ __ ] jumped in this room
didn't when I got out of it yeah I got
out of it yeah but yeah we were on
there's some sort of evil presence have
you felt anything like that since then
well at The Comedy Store you know that
that place is haunted
I haven't heard that's not Gus a couple
of times is that a ghost island yeah
there was a ghost named cause he was a
in the 50s he was a mafia henchman that
apparently was murdered at the Comedy
Store it was a club called Ciro's at the
time and I've seen Gus a couple of times
double that I don't people
Oh Gus levitated Sam Kinison by his
angle and above it because you know Sam
Kinison and Carla ball when they moved
from Houston to the Comedy Store they
used to sleep in the main room and one
night this is what I heard from Carla
ball cuz obviously Sam Kinison is dead
that one night he woke up and that Sam
Kinison was levitated by his ankle
upside down yeah huh I could tell I mean
next if I ever did this podcast again I
can tell you a million stories that
happened happened there really yeah
so when we do ours D when you saw the
goats just out of curiosity how did it
me and my friend Ronny Sanchez did a gig
at in Bakersfield is it back in the 90s
and I parked my truck at the comedy
store parking lot at 4:00 in the morning
whence Johnny dropped me back back off
at my car
we looked up and there's a window on the
top floor
we looked up and we saw a faceless man
wearing a table head with his hands
against the window look yes and then we
look at each other screamed we look back
up he was gone
yikes yeah so that's why that's
terrifying yeah
God bus thanks for sharing hmm let's
let's let that sit for a minute not that
I was done okay now we're done with the
whole podcast yeah we're done
Bobbi it was a pleasure man it was great
just to sit here and chat with you and I
had a lot of fun so guys thanks for
coming thanks everyone for watching I
hope you had fun I hope you had as much
fun as I did thank you that was great
it was really fun make sure to check out
Bobbi stuff we're gonna put links in the
description please support this
wonderful man next week we've got Harley
right from Epic Meal Time a very nice
cool dude and a good friend looking
forward to that so stay tuned and we
will see you then guys thanks for
watching God bless see you see you then